this is officially day one
of jaclyn's journey then i looked over
and there was megan fox and mdk and i
was like what the hell is going on i
like hit this goal that i'm going after
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
i'm becoming what i eat i don't want to
wash it no it gets so dramatic hey
everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
today we'll be tackling a really juicy
one
juicy chatting about jaclyn hill's new
controversial weight loss series now
before we get into it feel free to pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my general disclaimer
including a huge trigger warning to
those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and also do not forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode now please note that we do
film these videos well in advance and
these are my thoughts only on her first
episode so if you want to see more of
these definitely tell me below in the
comments and i'll continue to follow the
series all right let's dive into episode
one day one for the next 60 days of me
trying to get
in shape me trying to feel better trying
to have more brain clarity more
sharpness okay so these are all really
great goals and i do commend jacqueline
for making a commitment to herself but
why do we always need to put some
arbitrary timeline on these things like
why aren't we committing to behaviors
that we can maintain beyond like a one
or two month mark why aren't we doing
these things because you know even those
small little day-to-day changes will
make us feel better tomorrow
next month next year and ultimately for
life
you know what's funny is a lot of people
hate the scale i don't really care
because i know that technically i'm
overweight so i'm like it is what it is
who cares i don't really care what it
says i just care about how i look and
feel so there's actually two times in
this day that she gets on the scale and
i'm not sure the point in getting on the
scale not once but twice in a day if it
holds no power in this journey but i
also know that youtube loves a good
before and after weight loss
transformation and
unfortunately numbers do tend to play a
central role in this common trope but
anyways moving on honestly you guys it's
uncomfortable i don't care what anyone
says i put on about 45 pounds in two
years and it's not as easy to stand up
it's not as easy to do things i'm out of
breath all the time and then of course
not to mention my blood work my blood
panel show that i'm very inflamed as
someone with immense thin privilege i
may have no experience navigating life
in a larger body but i can totally
appreciate the desire to lose weight
especially in this kind of aesthetic
obsessed society i also have no right to
say that being in a smaller body
wouldn't physically allow jaclyn to do
more things or to feel better like this
is her experience it's her body not mine
but i do think it's always worth doing
some real introspective work to evaluate
our true beliefs around why we want to
change our body and i'm not suggesting
that there's anything wrong with having
aesthetic goals but i do think that it's
just worth you know doing a little bit
of that inner work to understand your
true motivations and goals now in terms
of her blood work that may be related to
her weight but it also may not please
know that research suggests that disease
markers like blood pressure blood sugar
heart rate etc can actually often
decrease after one engages in healthy
behavior even if those behaviors do not
result in weight loss so this is why i
always say that we want to make these
healthy behaviors the goal not
necessarily a number on the scale that
we may or may not be able to directly
control anyways let's see what she's
eating
choppy choppy choppy now avocado
perfection
now for the kale
i'm making a mess unsweetened almond
milk
okay so in this smoothie we've got
banana apple cucumber avocado kale and
almond milk and i love me a green
smoothie for a quick light meal and
while this one does have about 400
calories there isn't any protein here to
bump up the satiety factor and help
stimulate muscle protein synthesis now
research suggests that having a high
protein breakfast can help to improve
appetite regulation and can help curb
hunger and cravings later on in the day
so while we do have some fiber and fat
and all those fruits and veggies adding
in some like greek yogurt or silken tofu
or protein powder would make this a much
more satiating morning meal now i'm back
and i'm hungry i don't know if any of
you were like this i think i have to
like put something in my mouth every
hour and a half whether it's like a
handful of almonds or if it's just like
carrots i have to constantly be snacking
because i never feel like full okay lots
to unpack here first of all i would say
that the reason why jaclyn doesn't feel
full or satisfied is again likely
because she's just not getting enough
protein in that morning meal so a low
protein breakfast especially one that's
digested pretty quickly like a smoothie
is just not going to be enough to
sustain a lot of adults for very long so
it really doesn't surprise me that she's
finding herself mindlessly snacking
this is ultimately your body's way of
trying to find any little way it can to
survive i'm hungry now second it sounds
to me that while jaclyn thinks she's
eating a lot of junk or crap that she's
actually still stuck in scarcity
mentality where essentially she's
bouncing between eating clean meals to
binging on doritos midday so the
pendulum is kind of constantly swinging
between unsatisfied and bored to over
stimulated and stuffed this doesn't feel
good to anyone and yeah you probably
would unconsciously crave that kind of
overfed feeling because you know that
the alternative is overt restriction my
suggestion to jacqueline would be to
rework that breakfast meal to get in
maybe 20 or so grams of protein and to
include foods that we actually enjoy so
we're not kind of unconsciously always
chasing that satiety and satisfaction
all day long with these little tiny
snacks but for now i ordered ubereats
it's chicken breasts roasted veggies
avocado it does have brown rice in it
which i'm trying to stay away from brown
rice because not only am i trying to eat
clean i'm trying to stay away from
grains keep in mind i'm also doing this
to reduce inflammation ah
inflammation one of the most overused
misunderstood words in our wellness
culture lexicon technically inflammation
is your body's immune response to some
kind of stimulus it's a real thing and
while we do actually need some
inflammation in the body to like you
know elicit an immune response to like
stave off infections low grade chronic
inflammation is linked to oxidative
stress and therefore chronic disease now
in terms of prevention consuming an
excess of high glycemic index refined
carbohydrates may contribute more to
inflammation through raising blood sugar
and insulin levels but the brown rice in
that bowl is actually considered medium
on the glycemic index and research also
suggests that dietary patterns with lots
of fiber-rich carbs unsaturated fats
omega-3s and antioxidants can actually
have anti-inflammatory effects in the
body so unless there's an intolerance to
consider that bowl including the brown
rice is actually a pretty great
anti-inflammatory choice honestly eating
just the little bits of ingredients on
the top to me is just
not enough for a meal so my
recommendation would be to focus on what
we can add to a meal to boost the
anti-inflammatory properties rather than
focus on what we have to always take
away so the avocado veg and the chicken
definitely help as with things like
berries fatty fish nuts seeds and yes
whole grains okay so now we are at my
storage unit i have an entire storage
unit that is filled to the brim of
clothes that as i have gained weight i
like put it all aside thinking like one
day when i'm 125 pounds again i'm gonna
want this and i've come to terms i'm
never going to be
125 pounds like skinny little no muscle
jaclyn ever again i don't know who needs
to hear this but it is a normal part of
life to see our body shape and size
change i don't want my 19 year old body
anymore because for me that body doesn't
have the rich life experience that my
larger 33 year old body has and if
smaller clothes just brings on a sense
of guilt shame and of course physical
discomfort to try to squeeze into they
ultimately serve us zero purpose get
them out of here do not wait to live
your best life for when you are fitting
back into your high school jeans so i am
happy to see that jaclyn's willing and
ready to let go i know that that can be
really hard the last thing i want to do
is work out in any way shape or form i'm
actually in a really bad food i am
really stressed out right now i'm really
annoyed by um some people in my life
right now my family i want to get on the
couch in my comfy clothes and i want to
eat a bowl of pasta that's what i want
to do but i'm forcing myself i got
online and i looked up benefits of a
20-minute walk and there's so many
amazing health benefits so i'm like i'm
gonna get on the treadmill even if i'm
pissy the entire time just get a little
walk in before i end my day
oh my god have sweat dripping down my
chest and back
i'm so eyebrows and it's not improving
my mood so i do agree that sneaking in a
20-minute walk is a really great way to
boost those endorphins however
it's really not worth punishing yourself
over if you're just not enjoying
yourself and you're just like waiting
for it to be over if walking is jaclyn's
workout of choice throughout her journey
i'd suggest trying to make it a little
more enjoyable or even like therapeutic
so take the dogs for a walk outside in
nature uh go out with your friends your
partner add a podcast music or your
favorite abby's kitchen episode yeah i
don't know if that's something i want to
do right now or if that's not working
for you just try to find a different
activity that doesn't totally suck to
you i'm exhausted i don't know why
because i got eight hours of sleep last
night but i'm pretty sure because i was
dreaming about food all night long so i
had a dream that kourtney kardashian
invited me over to her house travis
parker was there and i began to freak
out then i looked over and there was
megan fox and mgk and i was like what
the hell is going on what what is my
purpose of being here and then courtney
walked up to me and said thanks so much
for coming to the barbecue i looked over
to my right and i'm not kidding there
was a full-on table it was just covered
in food oh dear now i don't think we
need to read too much into the
occasional food dream but considering
the context i don't know i think this
could be a sign that she's maybe just
not meeting her needs
[Music]
all right so two soft boiled eggs for me
so this is another day's breakfast but
again like this is just not
enough i am happy that we're at least
getting a little bit of protein that
maybe we were missing out on with the
smoothie but it is just a really light
unbalanced meal so she could combine the
eggs with day one smoothie or even throw
in a piece or two of toast to make this
more of a substantial meal i'm feeling
so frustrated right now after doing the
measurements there's something about it
this is very discouraging to me and i
don't want it to be discouraging but it
is so i have a lot of empathy for
jacqueline because i think i can hear
her trying to reject society's fat
phobic mindset and kind of position it
as you know how she feels in clothes but
i guess i would still want her to do a
little more work to ask herself why
feeling her body in fitted clothes makes
her feel gross ew david this sentiment
is steeped so deeply in diet culture we
usually don't even question it but why
is it so gross for our clothing you know
like highlight the shadow of our fat why
is it so close for our legs to touch you
know i'm not shaming jaclyn for saying
these things again i don't think it's
her fault for having these self beliefs
but i think it's worth her getting
uncomfortable and doing some work here
to ask herself why she feels this way
and a therapist would be a really great
support in this case and if she is
physically uncomfortable in her clothes
then again this is a really great reason
to clear out the closet but what sucks
is that when i get like stressed about
something or bothered or annoyed one of
the first things i want to do is just
like eat comfort food so i wanted to
know that it's totally normal to derive
comfort from food this is healthy normal
behavior but it can become unhealthy
when we're relying on food as our only
coping mechanism now the first step is
to build awareness of when you're using
food to cope with negative emotions
which it does sound like jaclyn here is
doing but being harder on herself to cut
cravings is absolutely not the next step
if anything it's likely just to set her
up for a binge what i would actually
encourage is more compassion and
patience as she finds some new non-food
coping strategies punishing herself for
giving into a mac and cheese craving by
restricting further will only set her up
for another binge an emotional eating
episode but managing the negative
emotions themselves through effective
strategies like therapy meditation
talking to a friend journaling and other
acts of self-care may help to mitigate
the root cause of the emotional eating
if you want some more tips on emotional
eating definitely check out my video
right here that's where i'm at on day
two i'm feeling discouraged just because
of the fact that i thought that i was
gonna be able to hang on a lot longer
than this now the fact that jacqueline
is drastically cutting back on so many
things in one go tells me that her
cravings may not just be rooted in
emotional hunger but also like primal
physical hunger as well the girl's only
eaten two eggs that day i mean what more
can you expect from the body so to me
the solution is not to hang on longer or
improve her willpower it's to feed your
body enough fuel that it can trust that
it's not going to you know starve so can
stop obsessively thinking about how to
get more food the chicken salad that i
had earlier really helped really held me
over and i felt good after i ate it
because i ate it with tomatoes and a
bunch of lettuce in the chicken salad
here we're getting some protein from the
chicken we've got some veggie action
hopefully some kind of healthy fat in
there for maybe an oil based dressing or
even some mayo it's hard to tell but
regardless
this chicken salad meal
still
super low calorie and again likely just
not enough to hold her over for very
long i'd want to see her add in some
high fiber bread crackers fruit maybe
some fat from avocado or nuts and for
goodness sake to make sure that there's
enough flavor and fun to elicit some
emotional satisfaction as well day three
i'm feeling discouraged
you know okay here's the deal this is
what happened okay i decided to weigh
myself this morning i've been eating so
clean what's the scale gonna say and it
said that i gained two pounds and point
four percent body fat here's the issue
with crash diets like this they put you
in this mindset that dramatic
restriction and misery will result in
dramatic results
fast i mean how could they not when
you've sacrificed so much the reality is
that weight loss is more of a marathon
than a sprint
that fettuccine
was sitting in my stomach like a rock
not to mention the scale is also not the
best judge of progress since there are
just so many factors that can cause
daily fluctuations in weight things like
menstruation medication food and drink
intake bowel habits hormones sleep and
stress why torture yourself
unnecessarily by weighing yourself every
day when it's not even going to tell you
anything reliable about your progress i
mean so much for the girl saying that
she didn't even care about the number on
the scale
it's lunchtime i'm here at the office
still have a meal prepped so eating
chicken pie lard literally just like
flat and chicken with arugula with olive
oil
is it just me or is this girl just
exclusively allowing herself to eat
chicken and
some kind of variation of vegetables and
that's fine if she truly enjoys it but
it's pretty obvious just by her attitude
that these meals are not sparking joy
and that to me is really the fastest
route to throwing in the towel on any
health promoting behaviors
i'm feeling good i'm feeling great like
i have good energy i know it's only been
like technically four days but i
genuinely feel like my brain is more
clear well i am so happy to hear that
jaclyn is starting to get to a place
where she feels good and has more energy
now it's possible that she's sleeping
better or feeling more clear-headed from
just you know having fewer refined
carbohydrates or caffeine in the diet or
it's possibly a bit of a placebo effect
we really can't know for sure but
usually this honeymoon dieting period is
typically interrupted by your body
freaking out because it realizes holy sh
i need more food making me a breakfast
sandwich it's like two o'clock in the
afternoon and i'm just eating breakfast
for the first time i've just drank water
all day ezekiel english muffin
with some sort of like sausage patty
an egg and a slice of cheddar cheese
that was the best breakfast i have had
the entire week it completely changed my
mood and i am so happy and for the first
time i feel like my stomach is like
yeah
that's what carbs do that is what food
you enjoy
does
yes i love this meal and i agree it is
the best breakfast she's had all week
even if she did literally fast all day
and just drink water to be able to eat
that small sausage breakfast sandwich
what was the thing
you needed me to come in early for um
the sausage egg and cheese biscuit but
despite it being again a very low
calorie meal especially for one that is
eaten after such a long fast we do at
least have some balance going on so
we've got protein fat from the sausage
egg and cheese plus some carbs from the
english muffin now she later comments
that this meal was not only filling and
put her in a really good mood but
allowed her to make good food decisions
later on so this is the benefit of
having meals that are physically and
emotionally satisfying ultimately
there's just less desire to binge later
on when we actually enjoy the food that
we eat i really do hope that she eats
more meals like this in the days and
weeks to come i am making a tick tock
recipe cucumbers soy sauce garlic chili
oil but we're using chili garlic sauce
honey sesame seeds and apple cider
vinegar
okay well
i thought we were headed in the right
direction
but alas now we've got like a mountain
of cucumbers
so i do hope that this was just like a
snack and not a full meal
but we haven't seen
any other meals for that day so
we can only help but we've got a little
bit of healthy fats in here from the
sesame seeds and oil i would love to see
this bulked up with maybe some carbs and
protein if she did want to transform it
into an actual meal so maybe throw in
some canned chickpeas or serve it with
some hummus and crackers for a really
simple light lunch now with all of that
said where are we nutritionally with
jaclyn's diet well i gotta say friends
not good
not good
at all i am hoping praying that
jacqueline did in fact eat more than
what she showed in this video here each
day because if not she's racking in
about 550 calories per day
[Music]
which is roughly the caloric requirement
of a single meal and pretty much like
less than half of what my toddler would
eat in a day so not only is this like a
quarter of her caloric needs for the day
but it also means that she's quite low
on protein fiber carbs omegas iron
calcium potassium vitamin c pretty much
everything
even if i were to give jaclyn the
benefit of the doubt that there is
another meal in there that maybe she's
not showing each day the meals that she
is showing are just
not enough two eggs that's not a meal a
little bit of chicken with some arugula
that's not enough eating the top
ingredients off of a buddha bowl so that
you don't have to eat the rice
not
enough it ultimately sounds to me like
jaclyn is going from zero to 100 with
little to no guidance and this all or
nothing mentality to eat less and eat
clean all while sacrificing any sliver
of joy or fulfillment in the process is
going to very quickly burn her out and
honestly burning out and throwing in the
towel is probably the best case scenario
here as i would way rather see her just
like tap out before it does any serious
long-term metabolic harm now i could sit
here and micromanage every meal but i
really would suggest that jacqueline
seeks out some professional one-on-one
help not only to help her unpack her
emotional relationship with food but
also to help her find a pattern of
eating that feels more structured
balanced varied satisfying and doesn't
leave her feeling deprived and miserable
i guess we'll just have to stay tuned as
we follow along on her journey so on
that note that is all that i have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you'd like to see some
more commentary on jaclyn series
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you